today Okajima was at tokyo game show and  he had more to say about his upcoming  game death stranding I'm Tony and this  game spot news update is quite a tease  we all know The Walking Dead's Norman  Reedus is in the game but what about  other characters Kojima stated there  will also be a female protagonist on top  of this the game will feature a quote  different kind of online play finally he  teased the game's release window  according to IGN  he said the game would be out before the  2020 Olympics in Japan then he said it  would be out before when the movie Akita  is set the classic anime is set in 2019  meaning death stranding is slated for a  2018 released death stranding is headed  to ps4 and PC assuming no delays 2018 is  still a ways off so expect a ton of new  information and trailers along the way  we'll be posting all the new info at  GameSpot and for all the biggest game  news you're already in the right place